[Music]
hey harry um
don't freak out but i know we've been
working on part three
for several days now
but we have to throw it in the trash
are you serious yeah we got to start
over i just got off the phone with the
nelk boys
there's so much to this story it's
convoluted competing interests
it's
we gotta scrap it and start over
this is the video you are going to see
about nelk private bet and wiza but
we've learned new evidence which has
changed our perspective on this not
necessarily making anyone look better
more like complicating the story and
making it more interesting so this is us
starting over and trying to make sense
of a bunch of competing voices
me
stephen dude llc and the knelt boys
enterprises bro like no one else bro
we're not going to take millions of
dollars
to
our fans ever bro
we won't take any sponsorship money
nothing bro like
hey guys in the studio at night here
just had to scrap the third video and
restart i mean look it's gonna happen
when you're doing something like this
sometimes the truth isn't what you
expect then other times the truth is
confusing or conflicting because some of
y'all
i just say it have lied to me
and let me say stop get some help no but
the point is is that everyone in this
story honestly it seems like they're
trying to make themselves look as good
as possible and it's hard to know who's
telling the truth like it's almost like
my job is a real life game of among us
who is the imposter telling me lies but
we'll get to that and we will catch
those people for now i just want to
catch up to speed and last thing if you
enjoy these videos please pump the stock
zilla by subscribing it's free might pay
monthly dividends who knows you know one
could say it's a gamble either way let's
go to the board and catch you up to
speed all right ladies and gentlemen in
the last video we explained how these
deals work with rhubarb these
influencers get paid millions of dollars
to stream themselves gambling but
they're not actually playing with real
money they're gambling with fake money
coming from a sponsor that they all call
howie we just lost 15 racks
all right well
let's call howie that was a test you
might need to call how you might even
really call harley off-screen
because that was
well let's see what howie's going to do
they just lost 15 racks if you look at
their bitcoin wallet here they're
sitting at a toasty zero dollars okay
god damn don't worry guys how he comes
in clutch look at that bitcoin wallet up
top their back to plane crash same exact
stream that we were watching god damn
they're constantly asking this guy for
more money because they don't want to
gamble a dime of their own money we
literally trace the bitcoin deposit
wallets of these guys they haven't ever
put anything in dude aiden ross didn't
put a [ __ ]
dime of his money into that bitcoin
wallet address how much money does aiden
ross have in the account 300
000 dollars ladies and gentlemen where
did he put the money in and of course
not only are they no stakes gambling
while pretending to high stakes gamble
remember because they're making millions
of dollars on these deals these
influencers lives are basically
controlled by ruben howie says jump
these influencers say how high literally
a kangaroo
bro why do you want me to do that howie
you're weird
bro
what are the eggs for this time what's
it hot bro
if howie says fly to mexico
you better fly to mexico we're gonna be
happy we're going to mexico hello we're
at this lavish luxurious villa this
other country i can tell you why we got
it why we got the jet why we did it why
why why we have officially partnered
with reubet it's actually quite bizarre
to watch all these cool influencers
dancing like puppets for rupet like a
weird version of squid game do a strange
task for lots of money
apparently howie has a challenge for us
no he's gonna make you do an angry sound
i'd bet you i'm out of this one i
that sounded like a kangaroo to me all i
got to say the money must be very good
for these guys to be doing that but of
course we know all that glitters is not
gold sometimes these deals fall apart
and it turns out this was the case with
the nelk boys and reubet and wizza see
many people noticed when the nilk boys
suddenly went from streaming every day
on reubet and being influencers on
whizza their giveaway sister company to
suddenly being wiped off the website
with no warning none of the nel guys
except for stephen dewitt remain
remember our boy allen is supposedly the
number one fan of full scent these are
the number one fans
of full sentence
well it all started falling apart with
the giveaway of a ferrari sponsored by
whizza that seemed too good to be true i
think it just seems like a scam because
it's too it's it's it's too epic yeah
it's too good to be true but it is true
famous last words huh i don't know how
to say this delicately but this thing
was a disaster part four will explain a
little bit more but this thing looked
completely rigged and all of this caused
an entire subreddit to be born called r
slash full scam and this subreddit
became devoted to cataloging nelk's
missteps in the meticulous and obsessive
way that only reddit really can now this
is where the story diverges actually a
little bit between what knox has
happened and what reddit says happened
the full scam page for the most part
thinks that nelk and wizza were in on
the ferrari giveaway disaster nelk
denies this though they said they had no
control and were working on it as part
of a standard promotion saying that
afterwards they immediately cut ties
with whizza because they suspected
something was up i of course asked for
proof they sent me this
this is from the full sin team on june
30th apparently they were mad because
wizard had charged their international
fans for raffle tickets for this ferrari
even though there was no chance of
anyone outside of the us winning they
said quote nelk has received numerous
complaints that its fans paid to enter
for a drawing on wiza even though they
were actually ineligible which resulted
in them feeling scammed nelk's lawyers
have advised that this was likely
non-compliant with applicable law and
accordingly nelk would prefer that
everyone be promptly reimbursed and then
a little bit later the breakup text so
nelk will not be able to proceed
negotiating the wizard or reuben
agreements further given the
relationship between wizard and rubet
and the recent developments
wow according to nelk they cut ties
early with wizard and ruben and honestly
that was probably a smart move although
it looks like not everyone was on the
same page because obviously stephen
dewitt didn't leave wiz and rubet we
also know lucas here also continued
streaming on twitch with ruben so it
seems like there are definitely some
outside deals going on which will become
interesting a little bit later now the
other interesting thing we learned here
is that when nelk backed out of wizard
they were also out of rubet nelk told me
this is because rubet and wizza were
package deals for them which if you ask
me is weird why is a giveaway company
and a offshore gambling site tying their
promotions together i mean yes they're
owned by the same people but it doesn't
exactly mix it'd be like a weapons
dealer buying their firearms to also
having to volunteer at the homeless
shelter or a smoking company making you
adopt the kitten for every pack you pick
up i mean it's a little weird right if
what nelk is saying is true i did talk
to another few influencers who said
their deals worked a little bit
different and were separate but either
way it raises a few eyebrows about where
the money might be coming from for all
these extravagant giveaways i mean
listen this might be the time for the
tinfoil hat here but go with me what
better way to get money for a mclaren
that you're gonna raffle off to your
fans than from a lucrative thriving and
maybe even offshore business you're
running not accusing anyone here i just
want to say that if it were me
that would make sense right but it's
important to say wizard denies the
possibility of this completely they said
quote wizard and rubet do not package
their expenses the two companies are
separate entities and pay their own
expenses no one is concealing the
overlap on the marketing team and the
relationships they bring to the table so
there you go take it for what it is i
just thought it was weird that for nelk
the deals were tied together and
speaking of nelk people were still upset
about the ferrari regardless of what was
happening and people quickly found out
looking behind the scenes that it wasn't
the first time they tried to give away a
car yes
is that yours how are you going to lambo
we teamed up with this company called
moose and they just approached us
they're like yo we got a full send lambo
we want to team up with you guys what's
the company that like how do you just
get a lambo they just hit us up
moose a charity company they bought the
lambo and then they
we push through our fans and then they
buy entries
and then so it's like one dollar entries
you can buy as many as you want yeah
basically the exact same thing
fans paid money for tickets to a raffle
and nobody really knows if the drawing
was fair or in this case if it even
happened no one knows what happened to
the full sinned lambo it looks like the
company moose gives was just a
fly-by-night company that folded up and
nobody got the car now once again i
asked nelk about this and they responded
quote we basically got left over in
almost the same sense as we did here
with whizza this is a lesson to never
partner with a company to give away
anything ever again they then talk a
little bit about the agency they were
working with at a time and ultimately
say the same as this wizard we really
know as much as the fans if this
giveaway was done legitimately or not
shortly after we fired wme for obvious
reasons and then they finally say quote
we've done barely any brand deals and it
always comes with the same type of bs
lesson learned for good this time so
that's their statement oh and they also
say that they were only paid 15k
apparently for this deal as well and if
that's the case i think they should have
just come forward and addressed this
stuff sooner um but speaking frankly
this kind of thing this giveaway thing
is kind of like a full me once full me
twice situation you know what they say
about that don't you you better not fool
me a third time but of course it gets
worse yeah because right after this
disastrous promotion with wizza and
rubet they literally start promoting
another gambling casino private bet has
a pretty sweet deal for you guys right
now they actually have an 100 deposit
bonus guarantee up to 500
uh all you have to do is use my code
kyle make an account on privatebet.com
and dm him your username and we're gonna
give away 250
250 dollars to a hundred people so all
you guys on privatebet.com 250 each
privatebet.com we'll be doing this real
uh we'll do this a lot
now this is totally weird for a lot of
reasons first of all
and obviously nobody's heard of this
website like when you look it up it
looks a little bit like like brand new
and that's basically because it is it's
offshore parent company uh xyz
entertainment as it's called was created
may 25th 2021. this thing's like a
little baby so why promote it i mean why
is a company like nelk not going with an
established casino instead of just like
a brand new one like this and this
immediately got people thinking there's
got to be more to this story and this
got even more damning when some social
media accounts called at blackjack were
found being used for private bat here
they are right here these have been
since privated and the reason they were
private is because they were tied back
by a youtuber named harrison
two people from nelk apparently nelk's
uh president the president of full send
apparently owns those social media
accounts the obvious implication here
being of course that private bet was
owned or tied to nelk more than
previously known which would obviously
make sense of the reason that they're
promoting this brand new casino this was
further confirmed on the blackjack
facebook page which was previously known
as private bet and before that known as
blackjack ventures and before that known
as fulsond blackjack now i would show
you some of harrison's video uncovering
all of this but unfortunately
surprise surprise it was copyright
striked by none other than elk now i
contacted milk about this because of
course this seemed extremely fishy and
they told me hey there's been a
misunderstanding they don't own private
bet at all
but they know who does but refused to
say
but apparently they were working out a
marketing deal with private bet and a
social media deal that's the reason
their socials were connected was because
apparently
nelk owned some gambling social media
accounts at blackjack and they were
going to let them use them in exchange
for a lucrative deal so private bet was
going to use at blackjack which was
owned by full send and fulson was also
going to promote them as a casino this
was the story that i was told but they
insisted that they never owned any part
of private now of course i asked to see
this marketing deal that was done and
they told me they'd love to show it to
me but it doesn't exist they never
actually finished the deal which i found
a little bit hard to believe nelk's
story is essentially they promoted a
gambling company offshore without owning
it and without a deal talking terms and
this is right after getting burned by
another company that they didn't own
does anybody else think this is kind of
a weird story i mean knock would tell
you that they only promoted it for a few
days before pulling out of the deal and
they say they're not going to do this
any longer but i know a lot of
influencers and almost none of them
would promote a brand or product without
any kind of deal first in writing
especially not a brand as big as nelk
you're gonna promote something without
even a deal sketched out on a napkin
i i don't know i just don't buy it and i
told the guys at nilk that i thought
that there was something i wasn't being
told because what doesn't make sense
here is that milk keeps saying they've
learned their lesson and need to stop
promoting stuff they don't control right
like that was the lesson with whizza
they didn't control it and they got
burned that was the lesson with moose
gives they didn't control it they got
burned and then their story with private
bet
is that they don't control it now when i
told nelk that basically i wasn't buying
it they said look we just didn't want to
jeopardize a more lucrative casino deal
in the future with an actual us casino
that's regulated but that's the story
you can make up your mind for what you
want to believe i just want to present
all the facts we have here i just
personally the story doesn't make sense
to me but around this time i was finding
nelk a little hard to believe something
even more unbelievable happened a
supposed nelk whistleblower suddenly
appeared on reddit on full scam
promising to expose them the post is
entitled my experience formerly working
for steve will do it and nelk hosted by
this guy zesty close the two giant
claims i want to draw your attention to
is one that private bet is owned by kyle
and the shahidi brothers and two that
the giveaway with the ferrari was rigged
for a stunt
i mean wow this could be big and of
course i instantly reached out to this
person i said are you willing to talk
and quote what proof do you have that
the ferrari is rigged he said hello i
would love to help but i just received
an email from the full sin team with a
breach of contract luckily they have not
determined who has written the reddit
form as i worked in the full send and
steve's accounting and another worker
had left the day before me and at this
point it looked like maybe this guy's
the real deal but he can't talk because
he's under nda so the question is how do
we get him to talk and as you guys know
meanwhile i'm in contact with milk so i
start to hatch an idea of maybe how we
can do this so my plan was i went to
nelk and i said hey
obviously there's this guy on reddit you
guys probably have seen it who says he
used to work for you he's exposing you
guys is he telling the truth they say no
i say prove it
and of course they said how so i tell
him look if he's not a real employee
release him from his nda if he's just a
fake employee he's just using this nda
as an excuse not to prove he is who he
says he is right and at this point i got
to tell you guys there's a pause on the
call as i'm basically asking them to
waive their rights to an nda they
discussed and they said all right done
any nda on this whistleblower of nelk is
null and void perfect so i go back to
our boy zesty close and i say hey i just
got off the phone with the nuke boys
they say you're actually completely in
the clear to talk with me so no breach
of contract to tell me everything you
know if you are who you say or you have
no fear of backlash john and kyle have
cleared you to tell me what you know
and this is when our guy our supposed
whistleblower zesty close it's his turn
to get quiet he doesn't respond and
suddenly his post which was highly
upvoted is deleted i asked why hello
why'd you delete your post he responded
hey sorry these last days have been
really busy for me sorry if i take a
while to respond and i didn't it got
deleted by someone else don't know who
though hmm
yeah i'm getting starting to get a
little
suspicious here so i followed up set for
several days and the guy just ghosted
right this supposed whistleblower turned
out to be completely fake and i gotta
say partially in defense of the nilk
boys here like look get mad at him for
the wizard stuff moose gives or the
private bet story of theirs but don't
make up stuff pretending to be an
ex-employee like if you're that
desperate to expose someone that you
fabricate working with them aren't you
worse than the people you're exposing i
don't know i just wanted to say that but
despite this being cleared up i'm still
not done with nelk here because believe
it or not we still have one final piece
of the puzzle and it comes from
lucas one of the nelq boyce also known
as gaspo show on twitch and by the way
this guy the second we mentioned we were
doing a story on rubet all his videos on
youtube and twitch were deleted i wonder
why same with steve will do it by the
way but anyways remember we said earlier
that lucas and steve continued to stream
on reubet well after june 30th when
supposedly nelk broke off the contract
and apparently it was because they had
their own deal well
lucas apparently was up to some sketchy
stuff according to a former moderator
who provided extensive evidence and
accused lucas of rigging stream
giveaways with rubet that's right if you
don't know one of rubet's big things is
all the streamers apparently give away a
portion of what they won at the end of
their stream it's the reason that rubet
streamers are always talking about how
much money they're giving away as lucas
explains all you have to do is create an
account with rubit and you too can win
make sure you guys are using promo code
lucas up here l-u-c-a-s collect that
[ __ ] make a new account do what you got
to do helps you guys out for the
giveaways a whole lot so
if you guys want free money man
all you got to do is that free money
that's right these guys if you use their
code they're going to give you free
money but apparently that's false
because allegedly lucas was scamming
people by not giving away money randomly
to his viewers but instead giving it
away to himself and his moderators
here's how it apparently worked
moderators would create a series of
shell rubed accounts brand new accounts
like this accounts like rix and morty
icy drops merch buyer several accounts
just like these would be created all in
the same day would be fresh accounts and
then would happen to win the giveaways
of lucas but they were really controlled
by his moderators who were feeding him
names the way it worked was allegedly
one of the moderators nate would send
lucas names ahead of time and lucas
would select the names that he knew his
guys controlled according to a statement
from the whistleblower quote nate had
set a certain type of order in lucas's
streams he became the main guy
controlling things like lucas's tick
tock account and making sure staff were
paid things stayed like this for three
weeks nate would message us asking us
for our ruben names and making sure we
would be paid and at first i didn't bat
an eye or anything and this guy went so
far as to actually send me the
blockchain wallet where these accounts
were winning on july 30th for example
when all these shell accounts were
created uh as you can see here are some
winnings on july 30th coming from the
rubid hot wallet itself and allegedly
lucas not only paid his twitch mods with
this he would also get a cut of the
supposed giveaways he was doing now of
course i confronted lucas on this
wanting of course to give him the chance
to comment he refused and instead i just
heard that he no longer wants to stream
gambling anymore not about figures now
what does all this mean right i'm
throwing a lot of facts at you guys
let's put it together for a second
please as we found out there's a lot
going on right contracts being broken
faking da's fake whistleblowers no story
about private bet which sounds fake to
me and of course lucas's fake giveaways
i think the common thread here is kind
of clear but more than that i really
think what we're seeing is a group who
can't decide what their ethical line in
the sand is on the one hand some of nelk
says they're done with wizard after they
suspect them of scamming their
international fans while at the same
time other members of nelk are still
their number one promoter you see one
part of milk say they're done with
reubet while the other part of nelk is
busy running a giveaway scam on rwbet
you have one part of milk saying they're
done with sketchy brand partners they
don't control and then they go out and
promote this supposedly another brand
they don't control because they never
had a deal worked out i think it's
honestly sad because without all this
sketchy stuff i think nell could
probably ride this full sin brand into
the sunset making millions of dollars
off merch and happy dad dollars but
instead it seems like they can't keep
their members from reaching their hands
in the cookie jar and if they keep doing
that uh the name full scam is eventually
gonna stick
so what will they choose i don't know
but i think what milk does next will
determine a lot
now coffee now is there
a way where it's like to just make
this like right
[Music]
you